not many Americans pay attention to
Canada the entire country could
disappear and it wouldn't make the
Nightly News here but we watch what's
happening in Canada because it's
fascinating how can such a nice country
become totalitarian so quickly are there
lessons for us
well for example a high school student
in Canada has been arrested
for declaring that men and women are
different Josh Alexander attended St
Joseph's High School Catholic High
School in Renfrew Ontario he was barred
from school from the grounds for saying
that God created two genders because
that's kind of a Christian precept also
common sense when he showed up for class
police arrested him you can see it on
your screen right now so we thought it'd
be worth talking to him and now we are
Josh Alexander and his lawyer James
kitchen join us thanks to you both for
coming on Josh first to you
um you were arrested because you showed
up on campus at a Catholic school for
saying that men and women are different
have we overstated that
no that's exactly what happened
um there was there was a lot of steps
that uh it took to get to that point but
female students complained to me and
they said they were concerned because
males were using their washrooms this
turned into a debate at the school and I
stayed in my opinion on it and I use
scripture to back that up and uh they
removed me from the building for the
remainder of the year and when I
attempted to attend class I was arrested
and charged
did you point out that this is a
Christian school and that this is like a
core Christian idea because it's like in
the Christian book which some call the
Bible
yeah absolutely I I actually tried to
have that discussion with my uh
administrators but they they refused to
do so
Mr kitchen my apologies by the way on
what's happened to your I think great
country
um what's your recourse legally in
Canada
well it's limited of course
um because our constitution is much
weaker and because there seems to be
culturally and legally much less respect
for individual rights and freedoms and
much more interest in
um you know government having the kind
of power to do what it wants
um but there is recourse to the uh the
Ontario Human Rights Commission in this
case um we think there's been religious
discrimination on the basis of Josh's
Christopher we just believe so we're
going to file a complaint to the Ontario
Human Rights Commission and there is
recourse through the board itself as far
as appealing these disciplinary
decisions and we hope to explore that as
well
I I mean Fidel Castro son takes over
your country and all of a sudden it
becomes Cuba like it's just shocking
Josh quickly to you the police officers
who arrested you a high school student
for quoting the Bible in a Christian
School must have been ashamed of
themselves I would hope did they seem
embarrassed
um I wouldn't say so I've had a lot of
experience with police over the last
couple of years uh just through the
freedom Convoy and other events like
that and the police state is quite
embarrassing in our country so no there
was no different response from them
are you going to continue High School
I'm certainly going to try to I would
hope that my personal beliefs wouldn't
exclude me from an education but it
would appear that's the way it's going
to be
it's an unbelievable story I hope you'll
both come back thank you Josh Alexander
James kitchen subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight